well you may have noticed that more
people today were outside
not wearing a mask that's because nevada
has now aligned with cdc guidelines as
more people become vaccinated
so should you still wear one when you're
outside christian casadas is breaking
down the do's and don'ts for us here at
six kristen
well denise it seems like uh guidelines
are constantly changing and it's normal
to get caught up in all this now take a
look here along las vegas boulevard
we've seen a couple of folks wearing a
mask others completely just
you know with their face completely uh
exposed here
so as of today we're going to break it
down here for you to see what is allowed
let's begin here
with fully vaccinated people cdc
guidelines say fully vaccinated people
can be outside without wearing a mask
but if you are gathering in large crowds
it's recommended that you keep it on
indoor use will continue to require face
masks like gyms
retail shops shopping centers and
businesses now this applies to people
who have received both doses of the
pfizer
or moderna vaccine or the single dose of
the johnson johnson shot
and have waited at least two weeks after
the full effect
great news for most while others are
still not on board
you're telling me you're not vaccinated
no i'm not but yet you don't wear a mask
no i don't think when i'm outside
i don't like to wear my mask you know
but indoor i do wear my mask
but outside i think it's fresh air and
we don't need to wear mascots does it
make you uncomfortable i mean
nope nope it doesn't
well if you're not vaccinated according
to health guidelines you should continue
to wear a face mask
indoors and outdoors this is obviously
for your protection
and others now the only time the cdc
says you can remove your mask
is if you're gathered among people that
have been fully vaccinated but again you
should still keep
six feet apart and keep that social
distancing now back out here live you
can see a couple folks
uh out here enjoying the nice weather
some of them again with masks others
uh do not have them now governor steve
sisalek signed the latest emergency
effort on monday with all these changes
in it he states that businesses should
continue to enforce masks wearing
indoors
and also they have the right to refuse
service otherwise
that's the latest along the las vegas
boulevard christian gossip is eighteen
is now